I'm gonna talk a bit about today about
kind of a new idea been percolating on I
like to think about new ideas lots of
new things I seem to be always trying to
think about something new and some of
them actually come to fruition this is
what I'm really excited about I think it
has to happen but to happen it's got to
receive funding so actually what I'm
doing right now is trying to figure out
how to pull money from corporations that
use open source heavily for their
benefit to actually move the community
forward because I've done a lot of work
and open source over the years numpy
Sipe I've been doing a lot of work in
business to try to bring money to those
projects haven't been entirely
successful in bringing the money to
numpy insight by that I really that's
why I started on a con it's why I left
academia it's why I went to end thought
the whole goal is to fund numpy inside
by we're just getting there fortunately
those projects have matured and
continued on even without my help but I
still have this deep passion to connect
companies and their usage we have
billions of dollars of value being
created in open source and being used by
companies and yet it's not funding the
fund of fundamentals the maintainer z'
the work going on is not properly funded
we ever wrote we have some work to do we
still have some work to do so we're
still trying to figure how to align
incentives how to make that work I've
known about this problem since I got
started and we that's a different topic
we can talk about I wanna talk about a
technology today I'm excited about but
it's gonna require funding it doesn't
exist yet but it should exist it's
called a Python I've got a name to it
now it exists it's got a name and it's
if the idea is how do we extend Python
in the future how do we really work at
building new extensions kind of little
bit and we'll talk a little about how
you do it now just quick brief many of
you know me but I've been doing this for
a while through many incantations my
recent one is Quan site still involved
as a board member of anaconda Peter's
gonna talk later he's still moving
anacondas mission forward excitingly the
Quan site we're basically a spin it we
see ourselves as the foundation what
gave rise Santa Conda we're taking that
energy rebranded as Kwan site and giving
rise to new things anaconda we consider
one of our first spin outs we have other
things happening so a lots happening
around the Kwan side ecosystem and but
it's all happening because of bright
people like you capable leaders who we
have to find and nurture and grow our
core business of Quan site is quonset
labs community work orders that's one
key way we're actually funneling money
from industry to open source directly
we're also do open open source
consulting standard services around the
pie to the stack Jupiter optimization
new custom visualization
EML consulting and we have staffing
mentoring a new innovative project
called residency that actually helps
people transition from academia into
industry so if interested in our
business come talk to me come later the
social please come talk to me
Quonset Labs is kind of what this katalk
is under constant Labs is a open source
research lab the intent is to grow a
team of 50 70 100 people maintaining the
core data piasa Python stack currently
we're about three you know continuing
our anaconda has about 1112 people so I
can sigh see this as a joint effort with
with efforts we've done before we also
have added a venture fund I'm talking
about that it's very interesting this is
to fund the companies and the spinouts
that come out of our activities so it's
an important key missing part that I
didn't have before but now we're pushing
it so python keeps growing so all this
activity all this energy of you know me
and my closest thousand friends in the
high data ecosystem
I've really done a lot of incredible
work and we watched this trend everybody
cares about Python now ten years ago we
were clamoring the door is plenty you
gotta care about Python Python something
important to your business now we don't
have to tell them that they're coming to
us going hey python is important to my
business but they're kind of confused
about what how it works how what they do
do I just take this fruit that's growing
off the tree do I have to water it is
there an irrigation canal I have to keep
changing what work in particular it's
the pandas scikit-learn jupiter
ecosystem that's really contributed that
some django some flasks but it's been
primarily this data science ecosystem
and then our friends at Facebook and
Google who have taken their deep
learning stacks and made them available
in Python and brought a lot of value but
also a lot of confusion to the work to
the ecosystem so we're working with that
it's wonderful it's wonderful to see the
incredible innovation that's happening
and Python is now taken over as the
dominant language yeah it's not exciting
which comes with its own it's new
problems and new challenges we're all
really excited and many of you are here
because of that Python is not just a
language it's this entire ecosystem of
thousands of projects each with its own
color its own culture its own story nunc
locust an organization that tries to
gather all those together and prize some
substrate and support for them but it's
a large story and the most recent deep
learning story on top has been very
exciting now that huge ecosystem of
extensions of python is why it's popular
python is popular because of all these
extensions how those extensions are made
also limits where python goes and so
that what I want to talk about today is
how do we make sure Python continues to
be six
in the future because the keys to Python
success in my mind a little opinionated
short list here
modular extensibility easy to extend new
types and functions easy to build
protocol overloading interoperability
I'm not going to go into detail about
that but extending Python have my friend
Ilan here Ilan wave I decided to use an
example from Ilan called bitter a
because it's a very simple example of
how Python used to be extended and so
how you can extend it today Python the C
Python runtime is built in a way that
you can extend and you can look at the
integer objects and every object and how
they're built and you can build new ones
and that's what Ilan did with bitter a
it's what I did with numpy it's what
lots of people have done to create more
capability in Python it's very powerful
and so you know there's you basically
can create classes in Python but
ultimately it's the low-level is to
underscore bitter a that is a low-level
C file that you have to define and you
create this extension module to find
names in it it looks a lot different
than Python like you're writing C code
and a command if you have if not
familiar with C its comparably good if
you are familiar with C you can
basically follow it and kind of see how
you do it and cut and paste programming
is is definitely how people get started
they take somebody else's extension
module they go and grab it and then they
replace it for their names but
ultimately have this table the table
maps names to see pointers so these
names in Python point to some c function
at the low level you find that c
function has a particular interface
takes objects pi objects every where you
have to unpack those pi objects into c
level structures right functions it's
pretty straightforward but somewhat
tedious and then there's a type there's
a type table and you make a new types is
how you make a new class so instead of
saying class in c you build this type
table right with all them effectively
the magic methods and replaced by c
methods so it's not terrible work but
it's work and that's the work of it
writing an extension module and you can
see these all over the internet you can
go and there's many of these look in the
Python source code and the Python source
goes full of this the C Python source
code so it's great super powerful but
does require care you have to you have
access to all the Python machinery this
is how Python itself works and how all
the objects run you can see that you're
literally extending Python it's as if
you were jido creating Python and it's
built in the standard library built-ins
so it's incredible speed is as fast
machines work you have access to all the
power but you have Tanel reference
counting which is usually where people
do people struggle it's you're managing
the memory yourself air handling can be
tedious the initialization can bite you
badly if you're not careful you have
pointers that aren't zero you access
pointers that are zero you access seg
faults galore if you're debugging this
and then other runtimes the big one is
that other run times in the past see
python was kind of iran time now we've
got pie pie and ironpython a jade on and
all the world loves you run times now
Russ Python micro Python there's
literally two dozen runtimes of Python
none of them can use your extension
module they all use the Python language
none of them can use your language
because you've written effectively a C
Python extension only and that's kind of
the state of the world there really
isn't a general way to extend Python
there's only a way to extend C Python so
not too surprising today it's a little
better like you don't really have to do
that today and I actually don't
recommend you do except in the most rare
cases most of the time today if you want
to extend Python there's great tools out
there use numba in most cases just write
numba and it does the compilation for
you and you can write a class you scythe
on so I thought with us for a while and
it's a great tool you can use it it's
kind of like a Python ish or use C C++
and then use PI bind I use an automatic
extension generator maybe you're using
my PI eventually my PI C so today that's
what you should do and only the most
rare cases did you reach out for
something this actually helps us if you
do this we're actually help for the
future as you'll see so numbers of JIT
compiler there's many talks on number
and I go to detail scythe on if you're
not familiar with there's a lot of tools
there it's a very powerful tool it's
been around actually since numpy came
out we used a version of scythe on
called Pyrex but now a scythe on is a
it's inside pipe and is usually written
these insights on basic use I'm gonna
skip over that for time come talk to me
if you're interested what about the
future we're gonna go from here where we
go from here I think is we've got to
make a way for people to be able to
extend Python with one syntax that then
it supports multiple runtimes
like it's really critical for the future
of Python that we do something like this
so we have this enormous capability
stack that we talked about earlier and
it's fantastic everyone loves it except
we have a lot of sadness for and I've
been part of that sadness with a pipe I
community ties a great project I've
interacted deeply with many members
Python project 10 years ago I told them
this is great but you're never gonna be
able to run numpy inside PI on this
stack unless you figure out what to do
and so they've done some work but their
work has been to kind of mimic the C
Python API effectively makes C Python
extensions work and that's great sort of
and it's sort of sort of it it works but
it's not really fast it's kind of bulky
we really and we get it's iterative and
you can do it what we really need to do
is move the extension community forward
get the numpy side PI all the people
from instead of writing C code to do
extensions you write something else that
then can be targeted to C code we
targeted pi PI B target or us Python
dots that's what this what I'm proposing
that's what I'm talking about doing
because these extensions ultimately are
fantastic capability and they give us
some more enormous present ability but
they're an anchor to the future they
don't let the Python community poor go
forward I was talking to the Python core
developers many of the the steering
committee and know that many of them my
friends have been around for a long time
so it but not know a lot of people and
it's great they're really excited about
these extensions but all of them would
love to have some mechanism to not be
anchored they love the success of numpy
but they recognize that numpy is also
one of the biggest challenges to moving
the C Python runtime forward numpy uses
the c python api extensively which is
great gives up some of its power but
it's also an anchor doesn't let the c
python api change much because it's a
lot of work to kind of keep everybody
forward so it has to be done in concert
there's gonna be a community effort to
move things forward together everybody
wants this to happen it just needs
energy and it lends some capital a
little bit of money to get started so
what do we need we need a way to extend
Python that targets multiple runtimes by
default so once you write your extension
you write your number you write your
graph library you write your really cool
algorithm you map you want to make sure
that that can work not just with C
Python but lease pipe ice rust Python
micro Python and JSON ironpython will
get our industry friends to help fund
that it's definitely possible and the
ability to add new runtime so somebody
comes out and says hey we're gonna add
this new runtime for Python pi PI we're
I trust Python micro Python they're also
sitting okay what about the extension
languages what's your extension language
are you gonna provide a runtime for
those extensions as well that had the
answer has to be yes that's possible
I believe the time has come we can use a
subset of typed Python the whole key to
extensions is you have to have types
you've got to have a types language you
gotta have some way to type data we have
that the mypie work has created type
Python we have type annotations we
actually now have typing optional typing
in Python but that optional typing can
become a requirement of e Python or
extended Python to create a domain
specific subset the main static language
in in Python so it's almost like ticks I
thaw and reframe it a little bit instead
of making a superset of Python make a
subset of Python with types and objects
were needed specialized objects were
needed in order to make things work so
that's the easy part
defining that language is not too hard
actually and there's a pretty clear path
to do it and then you've got to get
multiple extensions to go that direction
we're actually part of the way there so
I'd like we have to start over from
scratch pandas already is in scythe on
going from sites on a Python is a simple
it's simple affair a lot of people in
the numpy community would like to
rewrite numpy in a higher-level language
that's a pretty easy affair too so my
proposal is called a Python this a
Python is intended to be kind of in
between you have scythe on you have
number of my PI new tika eat pythons
kind of this right in the middle how
it'll work you have input file input
file is basically a subset of Python
it's a dot py file and then it runs
these through a Python and creates
extensions for the different runtimes so
for C Python we can already use scythe
on like that's an easy one actually
getting and then the other is that we've
got to extend that pipe IV extend Russ
Python extend micro Python to use this
extended Python so if we can get the
community to be behind the idea of Annie
Python then effectively Python becomes
here's the Python syntax and here's how
you extend it and if you want to make a
runtime a Python that's great but you
got also have a way to extend it that
supports this these type languages so
how so we could actually do this the
technology for this is not the hard part
that's actually the easy part I've got
people lined up who could work on this
I've got people in the pi PI community
were excited about it we've got people
and I'm Pyke me excited about it we got
the Python community excited about it
the one thing we miss is money I think
we need about six million dollars
all right so let's open up our wallets
I'll pass around a plate
maybe can do it right now no we probably
can't in this room but I do believe that
in the larger room of the world that's
not much money that's a very tiny amount
for the amount of money that's actually
being spent on Python the workarounds
that are being spent so the real goal
here is to actually create a mechanism
we call it a cooperative or a
cooperative community work order a way
for people to jointly to fund projects
working on open-source and that's really
the goal of opens of quonset labs open
teams a new initiative it's a new idea
to actually help this process as well
because e Python is just one of many
cooperative community workers it could
exist fact I think a lot of open-source
can be funded this met this way if we
just create a marketplace that connects
funding partners funding people with
managing people eventually what you have
to have is you have to other people do
the work some of the project managers
the work and you have to have someone to
fund the work and a lot of times he just
can't connect with each other they don't
know what's going on they don't know who
to talk to that the people have the
purse Prinze don't know about the people
that could actually do the work there's
just lack of communication it's open
Dave is a marketplace not here to talk
about open teams but happy to talk to
you about later have David Charbonneau
here he's the CTO I don't have Eunice's
here today
Eunice's our CEO oh we've got a team and
Henry we have a team working on this
right now
and in fact if we go to open teams comm
you'll see e Python it's one of the
initiatives this is a very alpha product
right now open teams is it's rapidly
evolving rapidly changing but our goal
is to have thousands of initiatives and
thousands of funders and a place where
they can connect and work together but
you can see it there it's still evolving
it's basically an embedded
domain-specific language intended to
help community members it's both
creation of the this product this
proposal is both the creation of the
Python language as well as the porting
of a few key projects to use it so they
can be targeted for runtimes so thank
you I have to answer questions later but
I appreciate you coming to PI data and
thanks for your patience earlier
[Applause]